does age matter
when i was in my first business it was a
biotech software company
i was 19 years old i had no idea what i
was doing
and i was afraid to sell
i was afraid that people wouldn't take
me seriously here i was i was i was 19.
i was selling the people who had phds
who were two or three times my age who
were experts in their field
i had no science background no computer
background
and i felt like i was completely
mismatched
it was me my two business partners
working out of an apartment
grinding it out and i was afraid that
if any of my clients actually saw what
what our company infrastructure was
they would be shocked and would not want
to talk to me they wouldn't want to buy
from us i had a great looking website
we looked professional from the web but
what we were actually doing i was i was
embarrassed by it
i didn't want people to find out i
didn't feel comfortable talking to
people
on the phone meeting people i just
wasn't confident enough in it
i thought i was too young
and i remember the moment where that
changed where i realized that it's not
about how old you are
it's just about your confidence and if
you can actually provide something of
value
the moment for me came when i was
working on a deal to distribute
my software in the uk a company had come
to us
and they wanted to represent they wanted
to represent us
in the uk i didn't really care so much
about the uk most my business was
to us and canada and uk was a great you
know little
piece but i didn't really care so much
they wanted exclusive rights
so i told them you know what if you give
me
13 and a half thousand dollars up front
i'll give you exclusive rights to the uk
and you get your commissions you get all
leads that come from the uk and i
thought
whatever like they're going to take that
and i thought
you know give it away who cares i'm
working on trying to build this business
in u.s and canada and they wrote back
and they said let's do it and i was
shocked
that was big money for me maybe that's
not a lot to you guys but when i was
starting up
i was like 300 a month this was 13
and a half thousand dollars this was
this was like winning the lottery for me
this was huge
this man i could i could eat you know
this man i could hang out with my
friends a little bit i'm not talking
luxury lifestyle just
any kind of lifestyle this deal got me
there
and i realized that they didn't care how
old i was
what they cared about was that i had
something of value for them
i had something that could help and they
wanted a part of it
and after that deal my mindset changed
and i realized that
it doesn't matter that my customers are
two or three times my age and they have
much better education than i do
and that they know their field way
better than i do
it doesn't matter because the tool that
i was selling could help them
and at the end of the day that's all
they cared about too nobody asked me hey
do you have a phd like i do
hey do you understand genetics like i do
no they didn't care they only cared that
i could help them with the problem and i
could do that
so it doesn't matter how old you are
people don't care what they care about
is can you help them
if you can help me then i want to listen
to you and i don't care
what your background is i don't care
what country you're from
i don't care if you have a disability or
not i don't care if english is your
second language i don't care about any
of that stuff that's all in your head
none of that stuff matters it doesn't
matter all people care about is can you
help them
if you can then they'll want to work
with you
and as soon as you get over that
limiting belief in your head
you'll start having bigger success
this comes out of a question from one of
my newsletter readers rashid who wrote
in saying
do years determine the level of success
and accumulating wealth because most of
the entrepreneurs the great
entrepreneurs i know
are in their late 50s
let's break that up if you're just
talking about accumulating wealth
the typical way people do that is
through investing right
and the more time you have the more your
money can work for you and it's easier
to make money
but if you're talking about
entrepreneurship
you don't have to be in your late 50s to
have success as an entrepreneur most of
the great
companies that are coming out now are
from young people they're people in
their 20s
who have revolutionary ideas and new
ways of seeing things
and they put that to work you have to
just have the confidence
that's what i was lacking i didn't have
confidence
i was so worried and hung up on my age
and how people would perceive me that i
didn't even try
i avoided talking to customers talking
to partners talking to media as much as
possible
because i was scared and i didn't have
any self-confidence
in what we were doing and i just wanted
the product to speak for itself so it's
so important
if you're in that place now if you think
you're too young
or too old or too whatever
it's in your head it doesn't matter
people don't care about it
all they care about again is can you
help them and if you know you can
then you walk into every meeting with
confidence because you're not selling
them now
you don't have to convince them about
anything you know that you can help them
that confidence comes through that
passion comes through
that commitment comes through and
they're going to want to do business
with you
believe you guys like this video please
give it a thumbs up below it always
makes me want to do more and please
leave a comment underneath man you
those comments mean the world to me i
wake up every day with them i love
seeing them so please leave a comment
let me know what you think
leaving comments spur people like me on
so get it going below you have a
question leave it below i'll make a
video response thank you so much and
i'll see you soon